I want you every [ __ ] morning on the
treadmill I hate it six to negative
twenty-five thousand dollars of debt
2017 made my first million by applying
your principles congratulations thank
you that's incredible I think that'd be
a great way to still compete yeah just I
mean that's like just like I'm sure just
landed in SFO and have to address
probably the most important business
question I've ever asked my YouTube
community which one of these stuffed
animals is best cool QD is it this
little puppy right here little animated
to do no but this pink monkeys love in
San Francisco which that's compas books
if they're getting crushing it
to keep that in mind okay
cleaned up a little bit just I can'twe
be free maybe pick an arbitrary
reversible ancient 20:21 whether you go
with that route or something else I
think you know positive versus kind of
look forward versus backwards but it's
about offense it's about throwing a flag
in the ground to the future right I'm a
big believer I don't understand when
people name and brand and market of them
looking backwards or looking at the
defense of it like you know yeah I'm
just people always like we're gonna fix
this or you know this was [ __ ] up and
you know this is that we're gonna clean
up the [ __ ] up tour instead of like
we're gonna dominate 2025 tour you know
it's subtle but it's real it's
positivity which is negativity years old
and I'm telling y'all a more sugar news
thank you so much
what you do is more important
thank you bye good thank you
[Music]
who's in the audience actually you know
what
why would great idea text the team I
think kids should go work for people for
free and keep it humble for the first
three years free to as little as
possible I think every one of you in
this room should like live in the same
one-bedroom apartment but get but work
for the best person you can get in front
of for free cuz the IP the intelligence
like you could read books about how to
play basketball but until you get on the
court the [ __ ] and that's what's
happening and so yeah I'm not trying to
be debbie downer
I just want practicality back in the
system because I think a lot of you have
to understand people wrap their
self-esteem up in their business you
start a new business you're 24 you're
telling your mom you're tell your homies
you're like I got this business and
you're [ __ ] flashing it and you put
entrepreneur in the title of your
Instagram and you're on you're on blast
now and when it fails all your
self-esteem goes with it and I want to
remind everybody 99% are gonna fail this
isn't 50 so like everybody who's sinned
like yeah yeah but I'm gonna break
through a cool but like 99% are gonna
fail plus the economy's been phenomenal
for nine years in a row now so all the
kids you're like you've got to be 32 to
even basically kinda remember when [ __ ]
was bad so if you're under 30 - you've
never been punched in the [ __ ] mouth
so you don't even know the difference
you think it's just always gonna be like
this you don't know what it really looks
like you're not winning and building a
business storing easy times the [ __ ]
you think it's gonna happen when no
money is around so I'm concerned but I'm
optimistic I just wish people got real
with themselves
[Music]
how you found me is like hey you looking
for uh I'm the director the guy who blew
so yeah you wanna be indie rock for
somebody yes and then i did a mother's
like hey I'm recording gears I do you
want to roll through it he's like dude
robot vlog we just did a fun podcast
where he's about to give some a keynote
get a lot of work done on email no the
Thompsons all check the country swerving
up the road from the road we got to
change that and do it ASAP
cuz i'll see you in a [ __ ] human
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
something that fascinates me because we
think a lot about money and opportunity
let me tell you about an opportunity
that I can't get out of my head which is
there's a website called Craigslist
there's a section called free where
people list [ __ ] that they want to get
rid of you go there and you take it and
then you list it on Facebook marketplace
and you sell it and when I think about
this I can't I've been dreaming about
this for the last 72 hours by the way
like I'm literally doing this selfishly
so do you rock capture this cuz this
videos going out like I you know it's
crazy to me that the only thing that
stops somebody from winning is education
and the work ethic right
I understand that but education comes in
so many different forms this is a
classroom of like 10 of 16 year olds and
they have to make money in the next 24
months or bad bad stuff happens I only
default in to go buy [ __ ] and sell it
and run the internet arbitrage become an
X we'll spend the first three months
I'll teach you everything about
Craigslist and eBay and Facebook
marketplace and let go and and then
we'll talk about China and buying [ __ ]
there and the arbitrage I would spend an
enormous amount of time because the
practicality right now in the
inefficiency of the Internet of buying
and selling stuff is extraordinary in
the last three weeks I've had these kids
who you know been following my content
and like Gary I want to get your advice
and basically both narratives with the
exact same way which is hey I listen to
you I got good I start buying stuff then
I hit it big a bunch of people made a
lot of money on the solar eclipse
glasses like you could literally buy
those things for like 16 cents in China
on Baidu
and then sell it for like four dollars a
pop on Amazon people made Bank like I
don't want you to make three hundred
seventeen thousand dollars like on a
three thousand dollars starting point
right so it's very real to me instead of
I'm gonna build some crazy app that's
gonna [ __ ] change the world right cuz
it's practical as [ __ ] and and both of
them have made real money one kids made
like sixty thousand this year off of
like a hundred dollar base right like
these are like real money and both of
them took it all and bought crypto yes
yes and I'm but like I believe in
blockchain is a technology out my ass
the the part of the story he doesn't
know is they bought at 17-thousand right
and they bought and they bought at
17,000 because they read 400 articles
that said it was gonna be thirty four
thousand and am I like crypt by weight
Bitcoin could be four hundred thousand
I'm not sure I don't know here's what
I'm disappointed in short-term thinking
when he goes who I'm not mad at I'm like
listen maybe long-term like like I don't
know if anybody's money situation let me
give you something that will really work
for you if you don't have to take it out
of Wall Street put your money into
Facebook and Amazon and I promise you
unless America melts over the next seven
to ten years you'll do well there's
something like there's certain things
that are just so black-and-white obvious
right and then everybody else is looking
for a lottery ticket I use an analogy in
a podcast I just did with some good guys
and it hit me maybe because I was in
Miami and stayed at the Hard Rock Casino
[ __ ] hotel which was [ __ ]
disgusting but but a lot of people are
treating their business the way you go
to a casino yeah you could have one
night where you took five thousand from
the casino but why don't you keep going
every night and tell me how it works out
they don't build Vegas on us winning and
everybody's treating their business that
way right now everybody's jumping from
trend to trend they have no foundation
of what they're actually doing the
writing only headlines and they're gonna
get exposed
instead of taking a meaningful step back
and doing a lot of thinking about a how
exciting it is to eat [ __ ] you know the
thing that the thing that works for me
that I really wished on everybody else's
I loved the journey I loved the game I
love to struggle
thank you oh that is amazing I think the
biggest impact I'm having is there's a
fuckload of sixteen-year-old boys right
now who think I'm the coolest and I'm
telling them to stop buying [ __ ]
Supremes and stop disrespecting women
and start [ __ ] being patient and
being kind and I think my impact on that
is going to be disproportionate to
writing checks okay I'm thrilled to have
that combo pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
life is good you did a really nice shop
and I'm really I don't throw around
compliments so easy really really really
really [ __ ] impressive negative
$25,000 in debt
2017 made my first million by applying
your principles real estate will not die
love you brother congratulations thank
you that's incredible thank you throw
your hands up in the sky if you kill me
that means everybody
for one it is one of
now more than that I did want a date
thank you guys thank you that is the
absolute quickest way that works oh of
course
it's it's siphoning off of people's
equity right so bye guys bye thank you
for buying bye guys thank you for having
me
all right what do you think Iraq why
can't we be free why can't we just a way
that is post